supergirl is about to make history
during a San Diego comic-con panel on
July 21st 2018 the CW announced that
Nicole Mane's will join Supergirl in
season four as Nia naal aka dreamer the
first transgender superhero on
television it feels fitting to say that
with great power comes great
responsibility
described by deadlines as a soulful
young transgender woman with a fierce
drive to protect others
Nia reportedly won't start out as a
full-fledged vigilante instead the
upcoming storyline will see Nia a new
member of catco's reporting team
gradually fulfilling her destiny to
become the superhero dreamer Nia is so
much more than the trans superhero she
is a reporter she is hopeful she is good
deadlines speculates that the
character's evolution from Nia into
dreamer will be similar to the way
Melissa Benoist Cara grew and matured to
become Supergirl as she stands today the
character is a new iteration of DC
Comics Nora now aka dream girl who made
a comics debut in 1964 and was given the
codename dreamer in 190 story line
Nicole Mane's made national headlines
when she was just a young teen after the
grandfather of a classmate at mains
elementary school complained to school
officials that Nicole shouldn't be
allowed to use the girls restroom and
the school agreed the mains family sued
her school district in June of 2014 the
Maine Supreme Judicial Court found that
the school district was in violation of
the Human Rights Act and ruled that
trans students should be allowed to use
a restroom assigned to the gender with
which they identify since then Maine's
has been an outspoken activist for the
LGBTQ community in 2015 Maine's on a
family with a subject of Washington Post
writer Amy Alice nuts book becoming
Nicole the extraordinary transformation
of an ordinary family which chronicles
the manes family's journey to better
understand and celebrate their
daughter's identity that same year
Maine's made a television debut in an
episode of USA Network's Royal Pains
portraying a trans teen and
choreographer named Ana whose hormones
posed a potential risk to her health in
2016
Mane's was featured in HBO's the trans
list a documentary directed by Timothy
Greenfield Sanders that highlights the
stories of 11 transgender individuals
including Caitlyn Jenner and oranges a
new black actress Laverne Cox
more recently Maine spoke out about
Scarlett Johansson's involvement in the
film rub-and-tug Johansson was set to
portray transgender gangster and massage
parlor owner Dante Tex Gale but dropped
out of the project due to subsequent
backlash Maine's told variety with trans
folks we have a lot of people accusing
us of just playing dress-up for whatever
reason and that's not true and so having
trans people play trans roles shows that
we are valid in our identity and we
deserve to exist as we do is for this
reason that Maine's involvement in
Supergirl is not just exciting but also
incredibly important and Maine's isn't
the only new addition to supergirls
fourth season April parker-jones is set
to play colonel Haley described by
deadline as a hard line career military
woman fiercely dedicated to a country
and loyal to a fault to a commanding
officers David a Jolla is also on board
as a devilishly charming and witty
antihero Manchester black Supergirl
introducing Maine's nyan Alice TVs first
transgender superhero sets an incredible
precedent and opens the doors for even
more positive LGBTQ representation on
the small screen
will we see Elissa yo bar girl's best
friend roommates and the transgender
woman in a DC series in the future the
Batgirl comic even featured yo getting
married in 2015 marking the first
transgender wedding in mainstream comic
book history for now we can look forward
to seeing Maine's team-up of the rest of
the Supergirl crew when season 4
premieres on October 14th on the CW
[Music]